alright hello everybody welcome welcome
so here we are in the outdoor boys
garage here and we're going to be having
a little Q&A and announcements and I've
got my wife here helping me out help
moderate and help me communicate your
questions but at any rate I got a couple
things were going to be doing and first
off we are going to announce the contest
winner yes that's right we had a contest
last week with my ninja throwing star
bandolier project and you're throwing
stars twitter and i will give you some
updates about what's coming up in the
channel and what we're gonna be doing
and we're going to talk Christmas
present ideas so especially after you
guys out there who putting together the
Christmas list for the for the mrs. or
you're trying to think of something fun
to get people we're talking about that
do some Q&A stuff as well so first off
the winner of last week's ninja throwing
star bandolier giveaway my project was
Mia's fishing I mean I'll be pronouncing
it right but McGuiness fishing he had a
lovely lovely comment about trying to
fulfil his boyhood fantasy of becoming
snake eyes from GI Joe and that that got
me yeah I got me good so so I he won
also he seems like he was over 18 and
possibly in a state where it wouldn't be
a felony to send him ninja throwing
stars so all big pluses hey everyone
looks like we got catfish bill 66 hey
good to see you good to see you man
I hope everything's going well for you
hopefully we'll see you at the cameras
conference this year yeah all right
and and Becca here will be shouting out
since I can't read the questions without
getting my face super close to the
screen Becca's good
about some questions as she sees him at
least a good ones hopefully and and love
you though they last a long time they
get harder are the jello hot dogs when
you put in the fridge they get harder
and harder but actually is good they
don't fall off the hook so I think I've
had some for like five months as the
longest I've ever had some but I've
never had them go bad they just it's the
longest I've ever had them downstairs I
was running around their skivvies they
believe that I don't think they put
clothes on all day there they're
enjoying the holidays so they're there
they're playing with their their aunt
downstairs so anyway so oh I promised
you guys also a bunch of updates about
things are coming up with the channel
we've got a lot of traveling coming up
we will be going to Florida here and a
little over a month and we're gonna be
doing some awesome videos including I'm
going to go try to catch pythons with my
hands in the swamp that nice so a new
video that
hey we got william way of fishing thank
you for the thank you for the super Chad
the $2 appreciate that I'll just spend
it on fishing but thank you so yeah
we're gonna be down in Florida with the
family and doing some fun things I'm
really jazzed to go catch giant pythons
at night I think you do with your hands
too I don't know a lot about what's
going on I just somebody said hey wanna
go hunt pythons in the swamp and I don't
like yes that's a yes so any rate we've
got that coming up got some fishing
trips we're gonna do some fishing low
down in Florida of course and have a
good time and then I've got a trip
coming up in January I was hoping to go
to Texas then fish or alligator gar but
everyone's telling me January's a
terrible time
terrible time to do it so I might be
going to Spain to go do wels catfish in
January yeah so I'm excited that's been
a to-do item for a long time so I think
me and Nathan might be doing that here
in January it's not official yet but
it's it's in the in the works but we are
going to England hey thank you very much
mark
I appreciate that thank you very much
and we're gonna be going to England in
August we're gonna be spending like
three weeks in England I think before
doing a lot of fishing and videos and
and stuff like that so it's a couple
different people we're gonna try to do
some videos with and looking looking fun
I'm trying to do something a little
different you know I really enjoyed this
world tour we've this last summer but I
think the videos were too much like a
family video log you know and I'd like
to do more more normal videos and less a
travel log you know or do a little bit
different than I did this last summer
but looking forward to it oh there we go
sounds no no no I've got I've got
several people who depend on their
paycheck like me keep the firm open I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna throw them to
the wolves just so I can go chasing fish
so we're gonna stay because I would be
doing the law thing for a little while
I've never gone deer hunting I used to
do a lot of hunting up in Alaska as a
boy but it's mostly upland game and
waterfowl cities to hunt sandhill cranes
and ducks and something used to do that
a lot I was a teenager but I haven't
really been hunting since I got married
hey come on look look at look at this
garage okay look at look at that look at
those fishing rods I don't need another
hobby
Oh Abigail thank you very much
I've been hillocks Adam Adam and he'll
that's makes it Adam he'll Natalie thank
you very dearly though I gotta tell you
I'm on the unthinking about hunting yeah
I'm gonna do a little bit more hunting
videos as the boys get older and that's
something I can participate with them
I'll tell you something I kind of want
to do a little sneak peek maybe yeah
thank you our what that's a boar spear I
really I want to get really good at
making Spears I'd like to go hunt boars
with wild boars of the spear hey I'm not
gonna promise you that this is gonna
happen but it's kind of a rough fantasy
plan you know and I would think would be
pretty cool so we'll see you though I
but as a father of three would like to
keep his legs
I'd like I don't have to do some more
research on it
hey Mike no pressure man just enjoy
watching oh there's so many wonderful
places to fish in this world I mean it's
it's just amazing anywhere you go
there's something awesome to do there
you know then that I think the secret to
life is enjoying what's unique about the
time and place you are at that moment
you know I grew up in Alaska right and I
was fly fishing for trout and salmon and
my dad spoiled me rotten me he took me
kinda like how I take my on all these
great trips my dad did
same for me when I was a young man and
and so I got to go and do some of the
most amazing fly fishing in the world
and got my first stage fly rod and
junior high and you know earned in the
safe of my money and I just really loved
it right and I moved down to Utah for a
while
and I didn't finish for years I mean I
was there for five six years never
finished because well it's not as good
as Alaska Alaska is better fishing
fishing here sucks you know yeah and and
the truth is you don't have some great
fishing it's not Alaska but it has some
wonderful wonderful fishing and I wasted
so much time by being snooty about it
and thinking oh this isn't allow this
isn't good so you know yeah and then I
moved out here to Virginia and Virginia
is completely different but there's some
amazing fishing as you guys see on my
videos right and everywhere I go that's
what you see you know what I used to do
isn't exactly you know this there's
something you do what you like to do may
not work in your new area but there's
always something wonderful something
unique that you can only do in that area
it's really good in that area and just
enjoying that I think is very much the
key to happy happiness no Jacob's
turning one here in a couple months so
he's ten ten month old almost 11 I've
never been turkey hunting you know I
have never I've never been hunting
outside of Alaska so it's uh and then we
do not have turkeys in Alaska so I've
hunted for ptarmigan and grouse and
cranes and geet actually it's not true I
I went quail hunting in Tennessee and
duck hunting in Arkansas those are the
only two times I've been hunting outside
the US oh that um yeah I actually got
that in the belly I made this when I was
a teen a teenager and this was hanging
up in my parents
they just recently sold the cab and in
my parents sent it to me so it's roughly
based off roughly based off a Twinkie
design I used to used to want to be mine
as a teenage idol
woodcarver specializing in native
alaskan totemic art so I made like
little totem poles and paddles and stuff
would sell them to people it was fine
but as I can tell you the great way the
Rue and a hobby is to do it for money
and it would carving is great I would
not want to feed a family yes it is but
in the tradition of YouTube we take a
long time getting to the point anyway
don't don't rush things here don't rush
it it's like a fine wine okay but thanks
Bethany Bethany thank you very much
Thank You Bethany good so with some
Christmas ideas as a couple things here
first off I was gonna tell you some
product and I really liked and also
inevitably I've been getting tons and
tons of questions about people asking
for my recommendations and they let me
tell you a couple things first off I
don't have sponsors okay there's a I
feature a lot of products in my videos
but I'm those aren't paid okay
most the time I'm buying these with my
own money and just doing it the
companies have no clue that I'm
recommending their products in my video
there's a few products that I really
like that the companies will send me for
free like my whisker seeker rods you
know I bought those with my own money
and then after having for a couple years
to company it was like ah notice we
really appreciate you using her module
send you some more anyway thank you very
much Steve Racine so there's there's a
you there's a few companies that say
this but I don't have any sponsors okay
so this is just my humble opinion of
things that I've found throughout the
year that I think are really cool that
might be some good Christmas ideas
because yeah you're you or your loved
ones or anything like me you're hard to
shop for is that right Becca so I'm and
I'm gonna be doing some follow-up videos
about this I'm actually gonna do a
formal video on the catfish and carp
channel with like fishing related stuff
like fishing related Christmas ideas
like these are the products I think you
guys should be looking at this Christmas
I'll hit on some of that this video too
but I'm gonna do a broader than just
fishing gear so a couple things
headlamps and I burned through tons of
headlamps I go night fishing all the
time we go out toed hunting with the
boys I'm always buying flashlights and
spotlights I'm tons of hey outdoor blood
thank you very dearly and I I have not
tried all the headlamps out there there
are tons of them but I really like the
coast ones they are some of the most
comfortable to wear they're light
they're they're pretty darn powerful
they have this adjustable knob on the
back this one runs off of three triple
a's pick them up at Home Depot or online
at amazon.com they run about 30 bucks so
they're kind of a mid mid priced
headlamp and you know the biggest thing
is the little little plastic things that
keep the headband on break and that's
I've bought like three of these for me
and the boys and stuff and the only
problem I've ever had with them is that
little plastic things breaking that you
can just kind of duct tape it together
and it works but works pretty good
pretty good head like so Coast headlamps
are great if you have a fisherman or
outdoorsman in your life who's outside
at night like camping if you want
something you know this is a nice
all-around comfortable lightweight lamp
if you don't want that if you want the
biggest freakin
headlamp you can get this is the
headlamp
we used frog hunting down to Louisiana
and they are insane they're so bright
you can see all the spiders eyes light
up in this swamp at night it's crazy
huge huge thing though it's rechargeable
it's got a little plug on it in the back
back it's it's not as heavy as it looks
but it's definitely heavier than most
more than just sticks out it's bulky you
know it's a big huge thing I find it a
little bit uncomfortable to wear just
straight on the skin but if you have a
hat underneath it it's not it's not so
bad but this thing is crazy powerful I
mean crazy crazy powerful so if you want
a heavy-duty headlamp this is it and
it's about the same price amazon doctor
one of my dudes i'm gonna try to put
links in the description i get done with
the live feed and go through and talk to
you put links in the description so you
guys can see how to buy that my wife is
the same she loves it in the house not
for family pictures
a couple spotlights you know there's
lots of decent spotlights
this one's been pretty good stanley they
makes it a little stand on it so you can
prop it up if you're working you need
hands-free and it's got a little USB
port you can click this button and then
use it as a battery backup charger so if
your gopro or your camp or your your
phone starts to get low you can charge
it off the flashlight and it just got
high low off switch and it recharges and
it was like 30 bucks I think I got this
at Lowe's but I'll put a phat max by
Stanley it's not - not too bad it's nice
have you dude I use this I keep this on
my boat all the time when I'm night
fishing you know you're trying to see
something see what's going on you
keeping a lookout for logs in the water
you're going down the reservoir and
things like that works pretty good and
then at the end of the day I just plug
it in recharge it and I keep it in my
kind of go bag for for fishing and it's
been lasting longer than most of my
spotlights I've had a lot of spotlights
that I like but a lot of them die pretty
quickly the batteries don't last
[Music]
actually I've got I've got about six to
eight I didn't get eight videos that
I've already filmed that are just
waiting to post the outdoor boy's video
I got about the same number on cats and
carpet I've got some axe restoration
videos coming I mean I've got access
tration videos there's some clues behind
me of things to come oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I've been doing a lot of forging
and some forging videos are coming so
you will not be disappointed and and
recently you asked for a knife ask for a
steak knife set so oh I you didn't ask
for that maybe you just mentioned it
like okay I asked for a steak knife
we just said you didn't have one yeah
the 50k uh the 50k car the ice I didn't
get any details by sauna thing it was a
huh yeah yeah I'd love to go out and
fish I'm assuming he came out of hungry
you know but you know I got pneumonia
and so I cancelled one and then we were
on the world tour and got super busy and
I cancelled the fall one and because of
that and I got a minute they were there
there are a lot of headache and I might
get back in to do
doing it because I'm rearrange my life a
little bit better or this 2019 2019 is
all about quality of life balance
to put in perspective the last two years
before I did the world tour before I did
the world tour I've been paying two
years since I took a Saturday off and
wasn't filming so I'm filming pretty
much every spare moment editing videos
every spare minute of my life you know
and and the videos for the meet and
greets never did very well they're like
throwaway videos and so yeah it was such
a huge deal to like give up a weekend
and they would put me behind on videos
and stuff so I really kind of didn't
like doing it but I have a little more
time so I don't know oh I'm thinking
about doing I know a lot of people are
asking but it's it's it's a little bit
of a hassle maybe we'll do it yeah I'd
be rail myself a little bit it's up
actually looking at going it's a it's
it's a members-only a club if it's euro
aqua but perform well but the people who
liked and really liked him so I'm glad
there were some fans out there they're
good we love them yeah we love doing
maybe it was a little bit too 12 parts
was a bit much maybe yeah I did go to
BYU that's where I met my wife and we
met we were both sophomores and yeah I
think we were both sophomores when we
met and by the time I graduated she'd
been teaching there for like several
years
briefly yeah one of us was a much better
student Oh somebody was asking about
casting products you know I think you
know cast King I've got mixed feelings
about the cast King Kodiak is a decent
rail I seem to like I like it
the rover I do not like and they are one
of the companies that heavily try to
work out deals with youtubers and and so
there there are our company that their
reviews are often paid for you know a
lot of people play that game some more
than others but it's it's kind of funny
how III never hear boo from any of the
big manufacturers you know dye washer
mono you know flooger you know garcy
those those companies couldn't give a
crap about me you know or you know like
whatever but I get I get probably four
emails five emails a day from these kind
of startup fishing companies or China
Chinese bass fishing companies who sell
on Amazon or whatever trying to get me
to write reviews for money and I just
constant people asking me to do that and
it's it's interesting to kind of see how
that world works and I'm very suspicious
of the people who play that game but but
I like the Kodiak I don't like the rover
I don't have any experience with the
cast King gear outside of that oh I
tried some of their their brain a while
back and I didn't like it the colour
faded immediately and the weave was
terrible but but that's it that's the
only experience I've had with the
products there's a store in Virginia
called hardwood in the rough that is one
of the most amazing exotic wood stores
in I've ever seen
you know and it's and luckily it's it's
you know I can I can make a little trip
I can I can go there and kind of stop by
unstuff and and and get it but they had
some amazing stuff I've got a piece of
teak over there that's salvaged from the
restoration of the USS Missouri I'm used
used in a product project today
they had pieces of wood from trees they
were cut down from civil fields where
you could see the holes and that can and
the bullet holes and cannonball holes
from that the Civil War battles and
stuff had created all these cool Berle's
and stuff and they've got some of the
most amazing wood I actually was been
toying with the idea of doing a video or
just giving you a tour of the shop
because it's a fascinating fascinating
story isn't it babe have you ever messed
with that fish roosters who have fun
reels the bishop footage of fun reels I
have once it only once I've I've got
some whisker stick rods that I really
like for the boys and I bought some
cheap seventeen dollar fish of fun reels
I bought four of them for like seventeen
bucks they seemed fine but the the knob
on the reel keeps falling off so that's
all I know about them
you know I you know I when I do these
project videos I am NOT an expert I'm
not a fabulous blacksmith or an axe
restoration expert you know I the point
of these videos is like I'm a dude with
normal tools who's just having fun doing
it showing you that you guys can do it
too that's kind of more my stick knife
sharpening is one of those things I am
not that great at I know I'm weak and
I'd love to be better at so I can show
you some of the things I have learned
but I haven't learned that much and I
bet I'm doing a bunch of things wrong so
that's one of those that's one of those
subjects like I need to do more research
before I do a tutorial on it
answer your Instagram yeah I am I'm on
Instagram but I'm too old to be on
Instagram you know being on Instagram I
turned 40 this year being on Instagram
as a 40 year old is kind of like hanging
out at Chuck E Cheese is a 40 year old
you know it just makes you feel kind of
creepy too old to be here you know this
is weird
so I post stuff but none of I don't
follow anybody on there I mean I have I
have zero interest of it and people keep
telling me to answer my Instagram and
I'm not even a hundred percent sure what
that means
like people leave a comment on one of my
posts I read it and I respond to them
sometime but if you try to send me a
message or want me to follow something
it's it's try Facebook you know
tradition for the boy the doctors like
hey have you gotten your flu shot I hate
needles I would much rather have the flu
than the flu shot but yeah and but I
want to be cheeky so I tell the doctor
no I haven't got my flu she said well
why not and I said well I don't want to
catch the autism you know just being
flippant and the doctor free like she
unloaded like a 30-minute lecture on me
I mean I'm just kidding no it was too
late too late
yeah lectured my ear off about vaccines
I really don't care that much one way or
another I was just but yeah don't talk
with your doctor about that apparently
that is like the raw nerve of the
medical profession so I need to do the
nose the nose thing maybe uh anyway
Christmas presents yes back to that so
another thing I'd recommend you know if
you want to keep a little stocking
stuffer for an outdoor person these
things are absolutely amaze
easing okay these are the the hot hands
adhesive and warmers we've all used
little hand warmers right these ones
just have stickers on the back and
they're a little bit larger I take the
boys out fishing all winter long and it
take a little four-year-old boy out on a
boat you know in the middle of winter
when it's you know 20 degrees out of 30
degrees out it's cold they get cool so
easily you just slap one of these on his
chest what I'm on the bag couple
whatever you're great and I've had some
times like I went fishing with the Leo
from extreme Philly fishing last year it
was like 20 degrees in Pennsylvania and
I showed up and I forgot my coat wearing
this hoodie and my overalls and it's 20
degrees out of it oh crap I get out of
coat card I'm just like free so I just
take a bunch of these slap them all over
I was toasty absolutely wonderful you
just they're absolutely the most amazing
world well five bucks for a pack of
twelve at Walmart I'll put a link in the
description but those things are amazing
I do in there's ice but Virginia just
doesn't get safe ice easily there's very
few places very infrequently we get safe
eyes I keep thinking about you know I
could do do it it was kinda like January
here I'm I'm really debating between
flying to Spain and fishing for wels
catfish which will get up to like 200
something pounds or going ice fishing in
Michigan now I really love ice fishing
but if I'm gonna get on a plane and take
a week off and fly somewhere to go
fishing it's kind of like I think I'd
rather go to Spain and catch 200-pound
catfish you know it's it's actually
cheaper to but so oh I want to go ice
fishing it's all my to-do list to go do
some ice fishing videos but every time
the chance pops up kind of something
else coming comes up so I used to do a
lot of it in Alaska we used to love love
doing it I'll tell you the secret to
finding a good spot you know because I
always with ice fishing in the city you
know kind of the the little lakes around
Anchorage Alaska there's lots of people
ice fish and the way he always picked a
good hole is he found the hole it was
covered in blood and scales and fish
guts and bait and whatever one was like
dirty you know like you could see the
slaughter and gore
that was the whole you wanted yes I have
and if you watch I believe it's part ten
oh nine or ten of my world tour video
you'll see us fishing at Jewel lake so
yeah yeah that's a hard one
Chris is the stuff I want to get them
and there's the stuff that they want and
Weavin you were talking about that just
the other day like like Lincoln Logs and
OBB
Tommy we watched Christmas story
yesterday and Tommy comes up to Bob
today goes mom I I really wanted a BB
gun yeah nerf gun we might get him that
I was thinking about getting them like a
pair of like little flies I'll talk to
my wife about this is Dave Jacobs been
eating the nerf bullets alive
Oh as some other some other great
Christmas presents I'm doing a video
review of this cuz it was so